denise hospitality giant mgm resorts
international is laying off
thousands of workers this comes as
casinos continue to struggle during this
pandemic
eight news now reporter oracle mana
joins us live near the strip with the
details and how
employees are responding orco
well kirsten mgm resorts is one of
nevada's biggest employers but it was
announced today
that 18 000 furloughed workers
throughout the company are being let go
it's unclear how many of them are here
in las vegas but now they're trying to
prepare for next steps
it's frustrating to be in the situation
that we're in
a major casino company cutting back mgm
resorts international announcing 18
thousand employees who have been
furloughed for the past six months
will be laid off on monday august 31st
it's definitely a financial issue
i spoke to one of the employees from las
vegas being let go who did not want to
be identified they got this letter from
mgm
which explains properties are still not
operating at full capacity due to covet
19.
given nevada's high rate of unemployment
workers are worried
when there's no jobs available and
you're not receiving any jobs
any callbacks it's very discouraging in
a statement mgm resorts international
ceo bill hornbuckle said in part mgm
will continue welcoming employees back
as our reopening plan progresses and as
business demand grows
laid off employees will remain on the
recall list which is based on need
position and seniority and they'll also
stay on the company's health care plan
through september 30th
still hospitality experts say we could
see more of this
as the pandemic continues to go on
it may be that more casino companies
find it necessary
to lay off more employees to make ends
meet right now the mgm worker i spoke to
says they cashed in their 401k
knowing that's your bread and butter for
when you retire
is is a frustrating thing
laid off workers can still see and apply
for mgm job postings before they become
publicly available
and also workers who return to work by
the end of december 2021 will have their
benefits resumed immediately
reporting live near the las vegas trip
tonight orco mana 8 news now